welcome to this video in this video I'll
present you a game that I just found
them and then you sir the news part of a
chess website that was about them the
recently finished open tournament in
Baku Azerbaijan and in fact the buck who
open is one of the strongest opens in
the world I guess it's a full of Grand
Master's um and in fact was won by the
top play of Belarus um Sergei cigar Co
um and I came across the game that he
played in in this tournament and this is
in fact um with black he's got black him
against Antone ko-ro-ba was the reigning
Ukrainian champion and if you know the
Ukraine now this is a very strong
national championship it was some played
to just a couple of month ago and it had
done every top layer I think except of
even shock of Cairo he's the number one
Ukrainian player but still an
exceptionally strong tournament kirobo
fearsome has made quite some progress in
recent month and maybe one or two years
and has broken the 2700 mark recently so
it's a very strong player but this makes
a the game you're about to see now I
even more remarkable so let's see what
happens score above place 1 d4 p.m. is
some default player and we gather names
of Indian here which is answered by
Quincy to the classical variation um
yeah this is probably the the main line
of the NIMS oh and has been played by
almost all 1d four players at one time
um castles now for black which is also
probably the main move they are a bunch
of alternatives
mostly d5 and c5 but dumb castles are
sound the main move right now played a 3
and of course black took white um
recaptured with the Queen so this is the
whole idea of this Quincy to move to get
the bishop am this ninja bishop without
any pawn weaknesses so why it has no CC
pawn but of course you see that why just
spend some time with the screen and with
the spawn move and so black has a good
development in fact them legs may move
nowadays this is remarkable because it
wasn't really an online on until I let's
say three or four years ago it's the
move d5 in which with her jump like
immediately tries to open up the
position um this is not what the Garko
played though he played an interesting
sideline which is d 6 um this looks move
this move looks a rather passive at
first but it has a very flexible set up
in mind and we will see what what
happens might have three now this is of
course not the only move white can also
um play Bishop g5 and trying for a set
up with f3 III which is a traditional
way to set up the pieces against the
setup black probably would play 97 and
something along these lines it's very
similar to the game but it's slightly
different in terms of white set up
because white has the bishop on g5 we
see in the game that wider intended
something else he played 93 as mentioned
and now not be 2 d's em and now III yeah
this move looks at first a bit passive
because it blocks this bishop but
White's idea is to fianchetto this piece
and then maybe make use of it on the
long diagonal
like place b6 there's no other way to to
get this Bishop into play so all very
logical we should be to bishop to be
seven castles and 94 so black occupies a
central position with a night queen back
and now f5 yeah this is really a
classical kind of setup in this urn dis
opening and it's it really dates back to
the days of names of each who invented
this opening he played this kind of
setup also with white starting with
Knight f3 and be three or one be three
even and it's am a very nice display how
to control the light squares after you
exchange your bishop on c3 so blank
established this very nice night on e
form and also has a very strong diagonal
with the bishop so on White's goal here
is to try to neutralize this bishop and
in the long run get something out of his
two bishops so this is the kind of
position well in the long run why would
be very good but he needs to really am
take care but like some activity that
it's about to increase even let's see
what happens he played before and now
look at six yeah and this is very direct
black wants to put the rook on g6 and
directly attack this point white plate
now d5 yeah this is some typical move in
these structures the ideas that white
wants to blunt this bishop and he's even
willing to sacrifice a pawn for it in
some positions um of course you must
check what happens now if black would
take the pawn if black would take
why would probably retake the ship here
and then white can win a temple to
through t1 and he will follow up with
Bishop b2 let say something like this
this is not at all clear but white will
have some activity along the D farm and
along the some diagonal and there are
even interesting ideas like this let's
say rook g6 and now white could even
think about sacrificing this exchange
now attacking the porn all these pawns
are a rather weak and it's some not so
easy for black to keep all these pieces
together note that this Bishop is really
missing now if black now tries to
protect a d5 let's say I'm with this
move then White has ideas like night to
h4 which makes this look this Rooker
look really silly doesn't have any of
any good square or let's say here it's
basically the same what should this
route do this pawn is also hanging if
you go to g5 you are might even face f4
and this Rooker hasn't approved so white
has chances in the center if black girl
takes the pawn and this is not what does
eagle co had in mind he played something
different and move which is much
stronger he played root g 6 first the
idea is that the capture only six now
let's have a look if white would capture
here then like simply drops the sir
Knight back to f8 and he has a very neat
way to get the porn back simply with the
night and then this night has further
interesting attacking possibilities to
g5f 3 and so on so I'm taking only six
it's not really what what why once
do he played we should be too yeah this
makes sense suddenly completing
development and now I think it's a very
key point in this game where black gum
played a very strong four think complete
the move c5 and this is very very strong
and not so easy to understand it first
why this move is so strong the idea is
if why it doesn't take on c6 now I'm
pass on what she did to come 26 if he
doesn't do that then this pawn controls
the default square and the idea that
white softness in this position is the
plane igg4 and to increase pressure on F
586 so this pawn really takes into
control under control over the most
important square here and if wide would
take on you 69 we have basically the
same as before as mentioned black will
get the porn back and note this pawn on
c5 it controls this light on it controls
deform prevents the night from going to
deform and it's really not clear what
white is doing in this position there's
very strong knight on e4 also protects
d6 so it's it's everything that's
working nicely together for four black I
think this whole setup looks looks very
good that black play TM white now took
as mentioned i think this is some the
reg of your best choice and after Bishop
takes he played rook to d1 trying to get
some play on the d6 pawn here that's a
funny variation if white would try 94
just immediately am attacking this
bishop I mean okay it looks risky
obviously to to move the slide away here
and
leave g2 undefended but I think it's
funny that this is really a forced made
already black can now really check mate
with group g2 and there's simply a
simply no way to save to save himself a
white look let's look King takes Queen
check and yeah they are there some
simple line cm this is this is nice and
simple so what what should why do
probably go here then you add a check
check again note that you never can go
here of course 22 h 1 because then it
simply simply check made so do not need
to go here check King edge for now okay
there there's more than one way to win
this position yeah but like has quite
quite fun move here push up f3 this is
very very neat now threatening queen age
six and yeah it's it's simply over the
firm what would take him got just this
mate this made coming and ya know my
computer for some reason has a problem
it doesn't want to move king air for
yeah but its King fo and Quincy for made
yeah soaking up for channel Quincy for
made ok but 94 is really am carolee a
suicidal move he played rook to d1 and
now just 27 protecting t6 probably am
preparing to use this route as well and
now g3 yeah it is very difficult to play
this kind of position without this move
as some this threats on g2 are so
annoying um it's it's really difficult
to give white some good at YC m how to
how to improve his play him it's really
difficult alrighty i think it's not lost
them but it's very difficult to play
this position black plate 'if I've now
yeah and this really makes a very nice
impression i think this t6 bone is not a
weakness at all it is covered by the
night and by the rook and black has
really great control over the center I
mean look at this bishop and this bishop
this is supposed to be whites from p.m.
the white white strom card and he cannot
really do anything with the bishops yeah
in fact them in this position I'm here
coral bar phone already committed them a
really serious mistake but as mentioned
it is very difficult to play if he am I
think he may be should place a move like
maybe queen here intending c5 it's not
doing so much black can just play here
and then you still need to make a move
it's very difficult white doesn't have
any porn breaks it cannot play C 5v5
doesn't make any sense at all it's very
difficult to improve White's position it
sort of needs to um yeah keep things
together and try not to loose
immediately but it's very difficult um
what he did is he played night to d2 and
it's understandable this is so annoying
this piece you want to want to get rid
of it but black have some very strong
response and this is Queen to h4 yeah
what shut down why do now it's really
difficult blacks threat is simply to
take on g3 and breakthrough so any
nothing move like this it's simply
answered by 93 and it's over and white
get some gets really destroyed check me
like this
this is the the big threat and yeah what
else is there if white would take here
this also doesn't help at all Bishop
takes and what now if white moves the
Queen now then yeah you can look at this
for a couple of seconds it's rather easy
to try to find for yourself and pause
the video all right i'll show it it's
this standard tactic checkmate yeah so
nice so why cannot take the night and
yeah what what should you do really yeah
11 ideas too yeah to return you to
return him after which um at first you
might think that night XD 3 wood would
be a good move let's check this quickly
night x 33 the the problem is it has a
very very nice idea if white would take
the Queen now you have a very nice
double check mate here but of course
white um doesn't need to take it you can
simply capture on g3 rook takes yeah
endless this looks quite strong but it's
just the draw like on likes pieces here
he would need to let's say half the
rukon f8 already two to play route gave
six now and you would win the game but
you don't have enough pieces so night XD
3 is not not the solution but black has
a simple move we can just go here and
now I'm you see that white has played 92
and 93 back and black in the meantime
has yet teleport that is Queen from e72
to h3 which is an obvious difference and
black now simply has the thread Knight
to g5 and deserve just wins the game
there's simply nothing white can do if
you look at this let's say here just to
make a move and that's down to five and
edit so what you cannot take because of
made on g2 so I'm like this technique
and yeah what should why do you simply
threaten this and there's nothing if you
go here then black has the simple
capture yeah it's full of full of nice
mates yeah so black winsome wins easily
after this and of course Nadia three
wasn't the idea that white white head
when you played 92 he played them Bishop
to have three trying to neutralize this
diagonal and still it was answered by
Queen age three and now four simple
thread is rook h6 and it's over on h2 so
not much choice for white he played rook
to you one to prepare this move covering
h2 like plate this yeah night back and
here this also position which you can
look at pause the video and trying to
find a good continuation for black yeah
I'm here black played a very effective
move Knight takes two three and yeah
this is this is rather strong what
should white reply now um if you would
let's first things first if you would
take here then just this checkmate
coming we already saw this kind of a
kind of idea so cannot take them if he
takes with the night you can simply go
here and it's checkmate and okay that's
this one left take on c6 but this is
answered by simply am light xf1 and the
problem is now not only Queen takes here
but Ruby g6 is even stronger this is an
immediate mate and it's made that cannot
be prevented if whiter would take here
then it's the right checkmate and
otherwise rook g6 just wins something
like this check knee and your mating
yeah there's mates all around so wide
white cannot take on 60 at the end
that's only one move and this is the one
that core above platy he took on g3
there's no other move but now black can
simply take here and yeah here's one
upon but that's not not all there is of
course they're so this dominating
diagonal and the threatening heavy PCM
so this is some winning position for
black rook d2 now Queen to g4 yeah like
three groups as pieces a bit yeah this
is good what was intending c5 for some
discovered check and maybe some counter
play on the 60 black just steps away
with the skin and white um it's
intending maybe to activate the night
yeah and this is also good like just
wants to use all its pieces this is
putting some pressure on c4 and yeah how
do you protect this even not at all
white rice for some des productivity
it's understandable you cannot just sit
in wait here and and yeah basically wait
for the end so why tries to get some
activity with this Queen IAM but black
now can activate the night evening use
it on a form can turn the end is very
near here Queenie six taking the rook
and it's just retreats here to UM to g8
to a very secure square because
and the pieces that you have are really
in the attack are really enough this
rook just secures the the king and like
isn't ending this and there's simply
nothing you can do why took d 694 queen
here and yeah note that of course like
it's not taking the exchange but plays
Knight to g5 which is much stronger and
this is a check made thread that that's
absolutely absolutely deadly um white
white simply has a move and resigned
yeah in this game um the white player
didn't really look like a two thousand
seven hundred grand master but the
problem really is that he got into a
such difficult position out of the
opening if you if you look at this this
kind of position luck here is really a
really terrible for what he has
absolutely no direct way to do to get to
blacks position so I think that's really
am a big question where where he made
the mistake i think around these moves
there must be some improvement otherwise
this is simply a great line for like I
think a very key move is the move c5 him
this was very strong because that really
stops whites whites active ideas this
Knight d4 move is simply not possible
anymore and also after let's say he five
there's still no way that white can put
any pressure on the center so you really
got into trouble only in the opening but
i think the Garko did a very good job of
of yeah converting this and and managed
to want to find a ticking game with the
night and I some nice meeting meeting
ideas on White's King yet take note of
the set up it's um it's very good if you
play the names Oh Indian on sometimes
I'm similar
can be reached in the bogo Indian also
um if you play this opening maybe you
should look at this this kind of setup
trying to get get into this kind of
position they are very very interesting
to play for Blackcomb very often you get
straight attacking games like this and
its really am it's still solid it's not
though that you're taking a huge risk or
on maybe our worse if white plays
perfectly it's really a very interesting
and playable kind of setup yeah thanks
for watching I hope you enjoyed it